while the original 1933 king kong is an
all-time classic there have been a slew
of imitators that slipped on the
proverbial banana peel
here are bizarre king kong rip-offs you
never knew existed
while king kong was a critical in
commercial smash in 1933 its sequel son
of kong which came only nine months
later was not
sending the kong brand back to skull
island 15 years later b-movie studio
film classics released its own
low-budget kong inspired movie unknown
island
the story should sound familiar an
adventure seeker convinces his
soon-to-be wife to finance an expedition
to an island supposedly populated by
dinosaurs
when they arrive it turns out the
legends were true
so yeah same basic story as king kong
although unknown island doesn't feature
a gorilla-like monster
instead it has giant sloths and actors
and dinosaur costumes
unknown island isn't the worst king kong
ripoff and at only 75 minutes it isn't a
big time commitment either
it's also in the public domain so
tracking it down should be much easier
than fighting off a horde of hungry
dinos
brad pitt once said he discovered his
love of cinema from touhou studios 1966
release the war of the gargantuas
released to american cinemas in the
1970s
most people didn't know what the hell he
was talking about toilet paper new cars
computerized blenders
electrically operated sexual devices
gargantuas is actually a sequel to
1965's frankenstein conquers the world
in which a green-skinned frankenstein
monster who is about 60 feet tall fights
a fire-breathing dinosaur to the death
before he is carried into the sea by a
giant octopus
got all that in the war of the
gargantuas the dead frankenstein's dna
is used to create sanda
a peaceful brown primate-like gargantua
who escapes from his lap
his blood creates a mutated killer green
gargantua named gaia
despite being brothers the gargantuas go
to war it's a lot but it's also pretty
awesome
the gargantuas have shown up from time
to time in other godzilla-related media
but there's never been a sequel remake
or reboot
india's bollywood film industry is one
of the biggest in the world but that was
most definitely not the case in 1963
when shikari was released
this may be the most impressive king
kong ripoff not because it's good but
because the filmmakers didn't even try
to disguise that it was a blatant king
kong ripoff
in the movie the owners of a struggling
circus set out to capture king kong at
kong island
so yeah not exactly subtle they're
joined on their adventure by a scientist
a beautiful girl and a circus clown
instead of kong they encounter otengo
the result of experiments in turning
humans into gorillas by the island of dr
moreau like mad scientist dr cyclops
yeah that's his name sound crazy it gets
crazier
we won't spoil it except to say otango
doesn't get nearly enough screen time
which is instead spent on the human
leads
shikari isn't particularly memorable
though the soundtrack to the movie did
become popular in india
we wished we came up with king kong goes
hong kong but the last celestial pitcher
snagged that particular tagline to
promote 1977's the mighty peking man
it's the most impressive part of this
picture which is basically what king
kong would be if it were made by a 13
year old boy
while every giant gorilla picture is a
rip-off of the original king kong the
mighty p king man is technically a cash
grab of dino de laurentiis 1976
blockbuster king kong remake by the hong
kong-based shaw brothers studio
if you know shaw brothers studio you
know what to expect if you don't it's
basically an exploitation eric king kong
with then plotting and a thick coating
of 1970s sleaze
even if you haven't seen it do you know
what it's about explorers travel to an
island to find a mythological monster
and bring it back to civilization
it's king kong but with hong kong
replacing new york city and a terrified
fey ray being swapped for pink king
man's companion a russian blonde and an
animal skin bikini
the mighty peking man was re-released in
the late 1990s by quentin tarantino's
rolling thunder pictures prompting a
glowing three-star review from roger
ebert
no ebert didn't actually think it was
good and you won't either but if you can
track it down you'll love it's
delightfully kitschy absurdity all the
same
ever wonder what michael goff was up to
before playing alfred pennyworth in the
tim burton and joel schumacher batman
movies
well in 1961 he starred in one of the
better king kong ripoffs
conga
[Music]
better is a relative term here conga is
still an embarrassment golf probably
wishes he never made and you'll wish you
never saw
what gorgo is the godzilla kanga is the
king kong abandoning the original film
cities and contexts for merry old
england
golf plays dr charles decker who spent a
year in africa where he was presumed
dead
doing mad scientisty things like turning
plants and animals into giant monsters
dr dekker brings back a baby chimp ponga
injected with a serum to kill his
enemies but the baby chimp grows into a
giant gorilla and causes destruction
across london
conga is a pretty basic cross between a
man in a gorilla suit movie and the
monster's run of muck pictures of the
1950s trading giant ants spiders and
condors with
well a man in a gorilla suit it's bad
but not quite laughably so
at least once you get used to the
character screaming bloody murder while
being attacked by a dude in a cheap
halloween costume
we're glad to say that 28 years later
golf graduated to another film about a
guy in costume attacking people
we're genuinely shocked it took 43 years
for anyone to think of queen kong
it was actually released before the
movie it was ripping off dino de
laurentis's king kong remake
the american blockbuster remake came out
december 17 1976 while queen kong
arrived on december 10
1976 but only in italy and germany
kong's then copyright holder de
laurentiis stopped it from being
released elsewhere
in hindsight we should probably thank
him for burying this movie because
nobody should have been subjected to it
honestly queen kong is less a rip-off
and more of a spook
the british german co-production is a
comedy adventure film and plays like a
gender reversed king kong
a female film crew kidnaps a male actor
and takes him to the jungles of africa
to star in a movie
there the actor also a petty thief
becomes the object of desire for a giant
female gorilla we applaud the efforts
not the result if you destroy this
beautiful beast
you're destroying a lifetime of female
struggle
it wasn't beauty that killed this beast
but the critics as its 23
audience score on rotten tomatoes and
3.3 score on imdb demonstrate
turns out that if you're gonna make a
comedy it helps to be funny which queen
kong is not
in order to be so bad it's good a movie
has to be unintentionally funny
queen kong is unintentionally not funny
which makes it just a bore
no one waves into the camera that's what
i'm famous for
not one wave
we gotta hand it to the american
distributors of king of kong island they
weren't even trying to hide the fact
that they were ripping off king kong
ironically this movie doesn't feature a
giant gorilla or even an island
don't be fooled however while only the
title rips off king kong the movie
itself is basically tarzan
if the lord of the apes were a lady in
fact the original italian title is
translated as eva the savage venus
this 1968 italian jungle adventure film
is about a mad scientist who is using
mind control devices on gorillas in
kenya
when he kidnaps a young woman a
mercenary adventurer leads a team into
the jungle to find her
along the way he encounters a legendary
white jungle woman wearing only a
loincloth that the natives call the
sacred monkey
coolest hero name ever maybe the sacred
monkey is actually an orphan named eva
who was raised by apes and who speaks no
human language but can communicate with
animals
despite her name being in the italian
title eva is only a supporting character
as the focus is on the adventurer so
it's called eva the savage venus but
isn't about her and was changed to king
of kong island in america but has no
giant gorillas
got it sounds like the ones getting
ripped off the most were the people
watching it
ape is probably the worst king kong
rip-off though it only wins by a hair
with a 2.5 out of 10 imdb rating and a 9
audience score on rotten tomatoes this
movie is truly terrible
ape is a 1976 american south korean
co-production
featuring a western director and stars
and a largely south korean crew
and was one of many giant gorilla movies
made to ride the waves on dino de
laurentis's remake the words
not to be confused with king kong or
even on the poster
oh hello hello if you should bump into
him
ask him if his name is king kong to give
you an idea of what kind of movie you're
dealing with consider the title for its
1982 grindhouse theatrical re-release
attack of the giant horny gorilla
honestly it probably made more money
with that title
there's also its signature scene in
which the gorilla flips the bird which
admittedly is pretty great
ape skips the whole journey to a
mysterious island setup and starts
aboard an oil tanker
where an imprisoned 36 foot tall gorilla
escapes and immediately battles a giant
great white shark before making its way
to shore
the ape is at large killing people
across south korea stalking a beautiful
blonde and facing off with the military
wash shrinks repeat ape is awful but
short so if you have 87 minutes to kill
honestly you should probably still find
something else to watch
both the original 1933 king kong and the
1976
king kong remake inspired plenty of
rip-offs but sadly peter jackson's epic
2005 remake didn't inspire nearly as
many however there was one noteworthy
ripoff 2005's king of the lost world
released by the asylum the cinematic
mastermind behind the sharknado
franchise king of the lost world bills
itself is a retelling of sir arthur
conan doyle's the lost world but let's
be honest
it's a kind of cash-grab mockbuster that
makes you assume the actors had to be
tied up to keep them from leaving the
set
come on dana
natalie what's the plot you ask a crew
crash lands in a remote jungle where
some are killed by giant scorpions and
some are brainwashed into performing a
sacrificial ritual to appease the
monsters that live there
wouldn't you know it king kong or some
giant gorilla shows up to stop the
ceremony
it's been a minute since we've read
doyle's book but we don't remember
any of this hey creative license right
there are bad special effects horrible
special effects and then there's the
mighty gorga
we can say with 100 certainty that you
can spend 45 dollars at your local
halloween depot and create more
convincing special effects than this
the storyline for the 1969 film pretty
much is just king kong
a showman short on cash travels to the
african jungle to find an overgrown
gorilla named gorga
there's something about a witch doctor a
volcano and all the usual tropes but
yeah this is basically king kong if it
were filmed by a 12 year old with a
super eight
here we go and action
how do such blatant king kong rip-offs
keep happening well because nobody
really owns king kong
as flickering myth explains quote the
intellectual property status of king
kong has always been a grey area
going all the way back to kong's creator
marion c cooper thinking he owned the
rights only to find out he only had the
rights to the novelization
which expired and went into the public
domain anyway it's complicated
japan was actually the first country to
jump on the king kong ripoff bandwagon
with not one not
two but three knockoffs released within
five years of the original 1933 classic
and eventually of course japanese studio
touhou dropped the ape right into their
own mega popular godzilla franchise
okay drop it
so if you want to make a kong movie you
probably can but have an attorney on
standby
it can't cost any more than whatever the
budget was for the mighty gorga
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite monster movies and weird
rip-offs are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one